we're on problem where are we problem
232 232 only a few left if 1 over X 1
over X minus 1 over X plus 1 is equal to
1 over X plus 4 then X could be which of
the following and you might have a
temptation to just invert both sides but
you can't do that just yet because if
you took the inverse of this it's not
like you just get X minus X plus 1 you
actually have to subtract or you could
say add these two fractions together so
let's do that so if we simplify this
left-hand side a common denominator
would be X times X plus 1 and then a
numerator would be let's see 1 over X is
the same thing as X plus 1 over this
thing all right because that cancels on
you get 1 over X minus 1 over X plus 1
that's the same thing as x over X times
X plus 1 the XS would cancel out you get
1 over X plus 1 so this left-hand side
the x's cancel out and you get 1 over
well we could just make that x squared
plus X right so now this simplifies to
the left-hand side is 1 over x squared
plus X and the right-hand side is 1 over
X plus 4 and now we could invert both
sides or just set the denominator is
equal to each other but it's just in
purple they're the same thing actually
so if you if you take the inverse of
both sides you get and I'll switch
colors just randomly x squared plus X is
equal to X plus 4 let's subtract X from
both sides you get x squared is equal to
4 so X is equal to plus or minus 2 and
they say then X could be well choice E
is minus 2 so that's one of the values
that X could be next question 233 all
right they have 1/2 to the minus 3 power
times 1/4 to the minus 2 power times
1/16 to the minus 1 the first thing I do
when I see negative exponents
just so they don't confuse me is that I
just invert all of the numbers so this
is the same thing this is the exact same
thing as equal to so if you this is the
same thing as 2 to the 3rd power right
when you take something to a negative
exponent that's the same thing as the
inverse of that thing to the positive
exponent so this is 2 to the 3rd power
this is times 4 squared times 16 and so
2 to the third is 8 times 16 times 16
right that's 8 times 256 and then oh
wait I'm going down the wrong path
because they have it in in a completely
different format so actually maybe I
should look at the choices before I
continue these problems so let me
rewrite it so they all have it is you
know 1/2 to some power or 1/8 to some
power so let me rewrite this I went down
the wrong road
so let's write all of these as powers of
1/2 so 1/2 to the minus 1/3 fine that's
still 1/2 to the minus 1/3 1/4 what is
that 1/4 is the same thing as 1/2
squared and we're raising that to the -2
and then 1/16 that's the same thing as
1/2 to the third power is 1/8 so it's to
the fourth power getting that to the
negative 1 and then that's this is we'll
just use what we know about exponent
rules and we've proven this these in
other Khan Academy videos 1/2 squared to
the -2 you can just multiply these
exponents so that's equal to 1/2 to the
minus 4 and then 1/2 to the 4 to the
minus 1 you multiply them that's equal
to minus 4 and now we have the same base
and we're multiplying them so we can
just add the exponents so this is equal
to 1/2 to the minus 3 times minus sorry
minus 3 plus minus 4 minus 7 minus 4 is
equal to minus 11 so it's 1/2 to the
negative 11th power which is choice B
that was a good lesson there look at
your choices before you go down some
paths because I was actually going to
evaluate this thing which would just
taking a little bit of extra time
problem 234
234 in a certain game a large container
is filled with red yellow green so let's
see there's red yellow green and blue
beads worth respectively so respectfully
means the same order we said the colors
is the same order that they're worth so
Worth's respectively seven five three
and two points each okay a number of
beads are then removed from the
container if the product of the point
values of the removed beads is 147,000
how many red beads were removed so this
is interesting so there's something that
hopefully will jump out at you about
these numbers they're all prime numbers
right so if you look at any number you
can tell how many of a certain prime
number there isn't that number by just
doing a prime factorization so let's do
that for one hundred and forty seven
thousand so one hundred and you'd be
surprised how quickly a number can get
smaller so let's see how many times
let's see does three goes with golden to
147 I think we've done this before sure
let's see three times let me just do it
up here 3 goes into 147 for 12 27 49
times so you get a three and you get a
49
all right forty-nine thousand I should
say you could do a seven and a seven
thousand and then you could get another
seven and you can get a one thousand one
thousand and then you could do two a
bunch of times so you get a two you you
get a well but the main thing just so we
don't waste time is they wanted to know
what color did they want to know they
wanted to know how many red beads were
removed right so red corresponds to
seven so all the beads you multiply them
together you get one hundred forty-seven
thousand so we've essentially factored
out all the 7s that we can fit into one
hundred forty seven thousand seven does
not go into one thousand at all seven is
not a factor so we've already solved our
problem they're exactly two
seven prime factors in 147,000 you could
keep going in this you know this is you
get a 2 2 times 500 you get another 2 2
times 2 50 there's a bunch of two's in
here and then you probably get I don't
know what else you're gonna get you
probably get a couple of fives in here
and then you'd be done but these are all
the 7s there are two sevens in 147,000 2
7 prime factor so there would be two red
beats and that is choice D D problem 235
switch colors 235 if 2 over 1 plus 2
over Y is equal to 1 then what does y
equal let's take the inverse of both
let's multiply both sides equation x 1
plus 2 over y and so we get 2 is equal
to 1 plus 2 over y and let's multiply
both sides equation by Y so you get 2 y
and actually you could probably already
eyeball that's actually there's an
easier way let's subtract 1 from both
sides you get 1 is equal to 2 over y
multiply both sides by Y and you get y
is equal to 2 and that is choice D and
you could have actually eyeballed it you
could say 1 plus 1 is equal to so this
has to be 1 so how am I gonna make that
at 1 that equals 2 but sometimes it's
easier just to mechanically go through
the algebra because sometimes you can't
eyeball it and it's good to just keep
moving forward problem 236 236 if a B
and C are consecutive positive integers
a B and C consecutive positive integers
and a is less than B which is less than
C which of the following must be true
consecutive positive so you know we
could say that so there's B would be
equal to a plus 1 and C would be equal
to a plus 2 or B plus 1 and of course a
is equal to a I don't know that helps I
just felt like writing that down
C minus so statement 1 they say C minus
a
equal to - sure see their consecutive
positive integers so C is going to be
two more than a so this is right
statement two they tell us ABC is even
ABC is even well instead of going into
some algebraic thing where I represent
even and odd integers and all that let's
just try it with two cases one where a
is odd and one where a is even so let's
say a is even so the numbers would be
two sorry would be two times three times
four right so then we would get eight
well you know what this has to be even
because one of these numbers are going
to be even right and so if you're
divisible and by definition if one of
these numbers are even is divisible by
two
so the whole thing when you multiply it
together it's got to be divisible by two
right either a and C or even in which
case this whole thing has to be even or
B is even in which case this whole thing
is even right if you multiply a string
of numbers and at least one of them is
even then that whole number is going to
be even because that number that's even
is a factor of that whole string of
numbers but anyway you could pry it with
two three four or you could try it with
three four five either way you're going
to get an even number so this is also
right statement3 a plus B plus C over
three is an integer is it integer well
let's let's let's think about it I don't
know let's say if we were to take a plus
B plus C why don't even if we were to
take you see three plus four plus some
of that works two plus three when that
works let's write it as so this is a
plus a plus one right B is a plus one
plus a plus two over three right and so
this is equal to 3a plus three right
over three B is just a plus one C is a
plus two you add them all together sure
enough you know you can divide the top
and the bottom by three and you get you
get a plus one so yeah statement three
is also correct this is always going to
evaluate to a plus one which is an
so all three are true so that is choice
E and I'm all out of time see you in the
next video